away we go with this weekend series and
you can feel it it's like playoff
baseball right now well it's certainly
uh not october yet but it feels like it
in a lot of ways at times you'll see him
in the outfield trying to protect that
and it's grounded to the cardinal
shortstop and mundo sosa
[Applause]
3-2 off of the glove of michaelis edmond
barehands and they get up
and vince velasquez on the mound to
debut for the san diego padres they
signed him wednesday exaggerated shift
the 2-2
and tommy pulls it there under the glove
of eric hosmer off the sidewall
and edmond in with his 40th double of
the year 40 doubles tommy edmond here is
goldie popped his 26th home run of the
season against the mets
the 2-1
goldie bass hit in the left center here
comes tommy edmond he'll score one to
nothing as the cardinals strike first
here's o'neill running a five-game
hitting streak coming into play tenth
pitch of the at-bat right here to o'neal
the 2-2
oh neil cranks it out to deep left oh my
gets an absolute rocket into left
tyler o'neal
number 27
three-nothing
st louis
overhand breaking ball lined into right
field and another hit for frazier now
eight for his last 11.
inside corner and struck him out
and michaelis has his first strikeout of
the night but they've really cut down on
that
backhanded sosa the turn
and safe at first what a play at mundo
sosa
sosa to his left stays with it don't you
dare make an error we're talking about
you two two swinging a missed strike
three he got him third strike out of the
evening for vince velasquez a one two
three inning
trying to battle back from injury but
that is a walk and the padres have the
lead off man aboard here in the third
inning the first walk of the night
issued by miles michaelis
it's a fastball and he gets it down
michaelis has only one play a little bit
awkward with uh edmond covering but he
gets there
swaying and a miss
and michaelis has strike down number two
got him velasquez pumps the fastball
beyond edmonds reach four strikeouts all
of a sudden for vince velasquez and
seven in a row retired
one ball and two strikes on fam who
struck out looking first time up and now
strikes out swinging three tonight for
michaelis
dylan carlson will try to start
something now with two outs as dylan
took a call third strike ending the
first inning
out to deep right
it's at the wall god
the rookie dylan carlson home run number
14 into the st louis bullpen
four nothing
redbirds
we both wanted the cardinals to add on
and dylan carlson took it upon himself
to get that done
on the ground up the middle long way to
go and sosa can't get the handle
and he ends up throwing it away 2-2
pitch and it's hit up the middle sosa
flips turn by tommy and it's a double
play
[Applause]
he misses badly with the fastball only
the second walk of the night both to
grisham
shallow right
and carl's in there to make the catch
well lumet enters his 17th game
got to hold the redbirds at four
four pitches and a walk the pitcher
walked the cardinal pitcher michaelis
got him 97 from lament and the middle
out here in the bottom of the fifth
inning
hits it softly arenado bare hands oh
what
only way to make that play
is with the bare hand
he's so good with this it's about one
step
when he gets it in the bare hand and
throwing off balance
i like that too into the right center
field gap for machado his first hit of
the night manny on his way to second
base and manny in with her two out
double here in the sixth inning
so miles michael is five and two thirds
and only three hits allowed tonight
a couple of walks and three strikeouts
and now mcfarland
ground ball
tommy edmond good work again by
mcfarland
and a leadoff walk tyler o'neill
and yadi is hit by the pitch
right in the lower back it looked like
ouch
got it back up slider to strike out
carlson two down the one two swinging a
miss strike three nelson gets that third
strike out of the evening
[Applause]
bam hits it hard and that's a fair ball
down the right field line tommy pham has
found himself the base hit back at busch
stadium lead off single here in the
seventh
hard hit down the line and that is a
fair ball headed for the corner tommy
pham is on his way to third base he'll
be held up there hosmer into second and
back-to-back hits to start the inning
for the padres
luis garcia 24 in the third innings
scoreless baseball this streak right now
[Applause]
wanted nothing to do with him trent does
draw his third walk of the night the
bases will be loaded with one out and
cronenworth going to pinch in against
luis garcia here's the 2-2
and that's set in the air out to center
field playable for bader should get the
first run of the night home for the
padres his throw goes to third and in
advance there as well sacrifice fly in
the pinch for jake cronenworth and the
padres are on the board here in the
seventh inning
osmer went second to third so now
they're on the corners for profile
looking for his first hit of the night
trying to work him away again
and it's hit up the middle into center
field for a base hit
hosmer will come in and score this is a
two-run game in the seventh jericho pro
far coming through again out of the
lead-off spot for the padres the 1-2
pitch
backs up and struck him out
a strikeout for reyes to begin the
eighth the 3-2 pitch
that
catches the outside corner it's a
strikeout
another heater and it misses inside ball
four
with san diego a half game back of st
louis for the second wild card spot and
assist cabrera
ground ball slowly hit aronado gloves
with time and makes a play
[Applause]
in the air
left center
at the wall and it's off the base of the
wall goldie to second base
trotting in with a stand-up double and
that's how we start play
in the home half of the eighth 3-1 pitch
to arenado inside and he walked him
the o2
behind him a wild pitch and runners now
to second and third the 1-2
hit him
second time molina has been hit
carlson's last hit with the bases loaded
was the grand slam that he hit in miami
the 1-1
and carlson sends a fly ball out to deep
center it's at the wall
grass
[Applause]
for the rookie
oh what a moment here at bush
cody whitley
last eight games the opposition is only
hit 111 against him nine and a third
and myers on the first pitch pops it up
shallow right and tommy edmund with the
catch and holds on and the cardinals
have won now six in a row
eight to two of the final over the
padres
[Applause]